We've been talking recently about the improving
numbers when it comes to covid vaccine hesitancy.
Some months ago, months ago, at this point,
almost a year back in May, we had somewhere
between two thirds and three quarters of Americans
hesitant about getting a coronavirus vaccine
when it becomes available.
Vaccines now are available.
We have two vaccines available, a third one
coming soon, maybe a fourth one coming soon.
And the good news is that the vaccine hesitancy
has declined.
As far as the covid vaccine is concerned,
it got down to 50 percent, 40 percent.
Now, about one third of Americans say they
definitely or probably will not get the covid
vaccine, according to the latest poll.
Now, it's good that the hesitancy has declined,
but unfortunately, especially when you're
not going to start vaccinating kids for some
period of time in order to get herd immunity,
particularly with these more contagious variants,
you need to have close to every adult in the
United States vaccinated to get to herd immunity.
So it's still a disaster that one third of
Americans aren't interested.
But this new poll did something interesting,
which is it actually broke down a variety
of groups, political groups, racial groups
based on education level.
And we have identified the most anti covid
vaccine groups in the country.
And three of these groups are Republicans,
those without a college degree and black Americans.
These are three of the most anti vaccine groups
in the United States for different reasons.
Importantly, and members of these different
communities will have different reasons for
telling you why they are skeptical of the
vaccine.
Now, the reasons that people tend to cite
as to why they don't plan to get the coronavirus
vaccine include concerns about side effects,
not trusting the vaccines from a safety standpoint
and not believing that they need the vaccine.
Not trusting the government is another reason
and not knowing that the vaccine, not believing
that the vaccine is actually effective.
So let's look at some of the numbers here.
Black Americans are significantly less likely
than white Americans to want the vaccine.
57 percent of black Americans say they want
the vaccine, compared to 68 percent of white
Americans, Hispanic Americans, very similar
to white Americans in that in that category.
Now, this, to some degree is probably related
to historical atrocities that include medical
experimentation with black Americans.
And a lot of my black Facebook friends have
been posting a lot about guys.
While we understand the historical atrocities
related to experimentation, we need this vaccine.
And what we don't want is for our community.
This is not not me speaking, but some of my
black friends on Facebook saying we don't
want our community to end up disproportionately
unvaccinated.
That will continue to perpetuate these unequal
outcomes when it comes to vaccination.
When it comes to education, Americans without
college degrees significantly more likely
than college educated Americans to not want
the vaccine.
40 percent of those without college degrees
say no vaccine for me.
Only 17 percent of those with college degrees
So that's not surprising.
Lack of education and lack of just a real
understanding of how the vaccine works, et
cetera, makes perfect sense that the less
educated you are, the less able to sort of
parse the scientific data or even know where
to get it.
That that makes perfect sense, not surprising.
And then, of course, Republicans more likely
than Democrats and independents not to want
the vaccine.
And that one is pretty obvious when you have
had a party that from day one led by Donald
Trump starting in when when was it right?
January, February played down the risk of
the vaccine of the coronavirus, played up
this idea of it's just the flu played up.
The idea of it's going away soon played up.
The idea of that that's in China.
It's not going to go elsewhere.
And of course, we know that all of those things
were wrong.
It makes sense that if you were part of the
political party that that not only spread
those ideas, but actually tried to use them
to justify reelections.
And that failed, at least for Donald Trump.
It makes sense that you would be.
Less likely to want the vaccine.
Why would you need a vaccine against something
that your party leaders have been telling
you for a year now is really not that serious
in the end?
So completely unsurprising as far as that
goes.
Now, at some point we have to decide what
are we going to do if a significant portion
of the population never gets vaccinated?
I do think that various types of businesses
saying if you want to go to concerts, we organize,
you'll have to have proof of vaccination.
You don't have to get it.
The government's not making you get it.
We're not making it out.
We're just saying, if you want to do business
with us, a private business who organizes
concerts or flies people around or whatever,
you will have to choose to go and get the
vaccine.
I do think that that will have an impact,
but there are lots of people who just aren't
going to get it unless something significant
changes.
I don't know what that's going to be at this
point in time.
And it's something we'll have to continue
talking about.
Let me know if you're surprised by any of
these numbers, any of these groups that are
the most vaccine hesitant.
We'll have more about this on The David Pakman
Show Instagram, which you can find The David
Pakman Show.
And while you're there, follow me on Instagram
at David Pakman as well, The David Pakman
Show at David Pakman Dotcom.